number three
I'm sorry little boy but this is it the
end of the line for you but before that
happens you'll have to apologize for all
the mischief you've caused
isn't that right now you're gonna kneel
before me and beg forgiveness you're
pretty I said kneel fala Lika from Black
Lagoon take a look at yourself now a
pathetic little brat who's beyond all
repair and like it or not this is where
you're gonna die Black Lagoon is a show
filled with great characters witty
dialogue and pop-culture references
while taking a look at what would happen
in a lawless territory in modern society
but you know what [ __ ] that hot girls
had big guns and explosions yes after my
earliest statement about lack of strong
female leads in anime Black Lagoon is
not only the exception to this rule but
the [ __ ] benchmark of strong chicks
in anime since every woman in this
series is so tough trigger-happy and
just [ __ ] mental that the Marvel have
just renamed the show [ __ ] be crazy
[ __ ] be crazy I mean for [ __ ] like
where else Kia Cee'd nuns grasp and
golden desert eagles the may terminator
and before I forget crazy killer
incestuous [ __ ] vampire twins
so with this show filled with wild
gun-toting chicks raining down from the
sky in addition to a professional black
man you'd think that it would be hard to
single out a character to stand out
above the rest but if anyone manages it
it's bad a licker throughout all the
crazy ass females no one not even the
main insane trigger-happy female lead
Revie can touch by the like in terms of
status superiority and love of violence
cuz while the rest of the girls feel
like young rash hot-headed criminals who
solved everything by putting a bullet
through it
but I like it feels more like the
experienced veteran who's been through
all that and can keep herself calm when
she needs to but you know that
underneath all that there's just a
nuclear bomb waiting to detonate and
this definitely shows in the way that
even with all these psychotic people
running around she manages to generate a
mixture of fear and respect more these
outlaws as the leader of Hotel Moscow
she spent her time growing up on the
frontlines in a warzone off Afghanistan
with the guidance of her leadership and
tactics her comrades became unstoppable
killing machines gathering the skills
and experience of real war years later
she returned from that hellhole of a
battlefield with her soldiers to found
the Russian gang screwed as now known as
Hotel Moscow where her immediate
subordinates have enough training and
firepower to fight and win world war 3
all who are under the control of one
class a crazy [ __ ] based in a fictional
Thai city of Rana / Oh Thailand a city
full of prostitutes drug lords and Mafia
bosses where illegal activities are norm
and it's apparently a custom to greet
each other with a hell of bullets and
explosions
she often at times acts as the
peacemaker with all the violence
breaking out stopping the violence in
the most tactical and intelligent way
possible more violence as a combat
officer she's a skilled strategist in a
well round fight er capable of taking
care of herself despite a fact that all
his subordinates seems to worry about
her and there's a great sense of
camaraderie within her organization she
can be easily identified by her burn
marks rich scar her face neck and chest
earning her the name Frey faced by the
people who dislike her though I'd like
to see what happens to anyone who had
the guts to call her that in front of
her face because in Soviet Russia neck
breaks you but what makes are so cool is
that even though she has the skills and
psyche to go toe-to-toe with these other
crazy girls she doesn't even need to
cause she has all every other psychotic
character in this show is missing brains
as a master in war strategy and tactics
she can pull off operations without ever
having to dirty her own fingers or
sacrifice any of her men which is what
makes her and her group damn right
unstoppable and with all this mixed
together she is possibly the strongest
female character I've seen in anime
insert obligatory sexist kitchen joke
here she's able to maintain herself with
an air of professionalism when doing
business but beneath that calm exterior
she puts on she loves violence just as
much if not more than these other girls
I mean it's been said that if she had
the choice between having sex and going
toward then she would easily have chosen
war and you just have the gut feeling
that she could just snap at any second
and if she does then you definitely want
to get the [ __ ] out of there ASAP
because whether you live or die can be
entirely decided on her whim no it isn't
enough there are two things to remember
when you're begging for your life one is
to try and entertain the person holding
the gun to your head and the other is to
give that person a convincing reason why
they shouldn't kill you
but you haven't managed to do whether
one of them
things so let's hear it so in an anime
filled with psychotic cows due to
instead obligatory sexist PMS joke here
not unlike a stanza as the professional
leader of Hotel Moscow that earned
respect and whose love of violence is
not dwarfed by anyone while having an
entire army at her disposal number two
[Music]
I was supposed to die that night you're
the one who resurrected me doctor
Johan liebert from Monster
[Music]
Kenzo Tenma is a genius neurosurgeon who
chose to save the life of a young boy
rather than the life of the city mayor a
decision which cost him his reputation
and future as a doctor little does he
know that this is in fact the least of
his worries as it seemed dawns on him
years later after a string of murders
that in saving the boy's life he has in
fact resurrected a monster
[Music]
okay I'm just gonna be honest here I
tried really hard to think up some jokes
that would make this segment a bit
funnier but no matter how hard I tried I
just couldn't Johann was just too cool
and to spine cheating least scary that I
couldn't even think up anything funny to
say so just a quick warning now all this
is just gonna be my serious opinion but
to be honest if there's one character
that deserves your undivided attention
its Johann cuz if you think light yagami
is the master of manipulation and
deception then Johann is the undisputed
God let me just give you an example what
this guy can do at an institution he was
in Johan led a revolt between his staff
and the patients while only using the
power of his word and without lifting a
finger he managed to get 50 people to go
mad and start killing each other as he
just sat at the top like a god
witnessing the massacre that was
befallen around him until he was the
only remaining survivor this was when he
was at the age of 10 do you know what he
meant by that I simply added a bit of
fuel to the hatred born when people come
together it was easy that's what he told
me only 10 years old and he said that
and he did it with almost no effort at
all
he was able to make 50 people kill each
other without even moving your finger as
an adult he's only grown smarter more
charismatic and more manipulative
children see him as his idols serial
killers think of him as a holy being and
other groups of people trust and worship
him as if he's a next Hitler or frickin
Antichrist and yet every single one of
them dies and the most frightening thing
about this guy's how everything about
him largely remains a mystery
though we find out bits and pieces about
his past Allah has left to our own
imagination as a child Johan was raised
in an orphanage called 5-1-1 kinder hide
a top-secret research project with the
intention of raising up the perfect
emotionless killing machines by using
behavior modifications and brainwashing
techniques results for the different
children of this experiment varied from
memory loss to split personalities but
as for Johan you can have turned out
more perfect though while this guy's
chilling enough to give you nightmares
Oh God you look cool while doing it as
the charismatic devil was after years he
can manipulate anyone he needs to with
just the use of conversation superpowers
nope
magical notes book loke unlimited funds
nope
johan has such a strong grasp of
manipulation there are multiple
occasions he has literally driven people
to commit suicide whether they be
powerful leaders
real killers are just normal civilians
or seemingly because it's just more fun
to drive people to kill themselves he
knows exactly when and what to say to
drive someone into a psychological
corner as if it was his own art form and
no more is is obvious with his encounter
with an alcoholic police officer when
after few friendly drinks and some
chatter all it takes is a short of
verbal confrontation and one perfectly
placed line to send him literally over
the edge well Richard how about a drink
throughout the series Johan is more of a
presence than anything else we can just
feel his hand at work manipulating
everything behind the scenes as Tenma is
chasing him even though most of the time
he's not even there this builds him up
like he's some sort of omnipotent God
and it just gets scarier since we can
only guess at how he got this way it was
hinted out that Johan was the perfect
killer even before entering the
orphanage making us question if he will
somehow program this way or if he was
just born evil and if anything wise twin
sister didn't turn out like him as well
and okay okay okay okay one joke one
joke yes being a twin he can very
creepley do a great impression of his
twin sister right down to a voice and
honestly while I can't put him down for
being a surprisingly great crossdresser
I just can't because unlike someone like
alucard which is the really scary kind
of creepy this guy is most definitely
the cool kind of creepy the kind of guy
that doesn't even need to do anything to
terrify you all it takes is just one
brief look at that creepy smile of his
and it'll send chills rushing down your
spine because his looks his reputation
and just the feeling that behind that
calm sophisticated front there's just a
terrifying monster lurking behind and
you can do nothing but speculate at the
petrifying thoughts that could be
swimming in his head cuz there's nothing
that is scarier than the unknown it's
been stated that his goal is to be the
last person on earth alive when the
world ends but in reality his true goal
is in my opinion a lot cooler he wants
to commit to what he calls the perfect
suicide killing himself without leaving
a trace of physical evidence of his
existence save for those memories within
dr. Tenma that will forever haunt the
nightmares of anyone he feels as ghosts
the presence around as if he's the
personification of pure Eve
and that's not a cool ask oh I don't
know what is so as one of the greatest
villains to ever grace the medium of
anime and manga Johan is the blond devil
who is the perfect monster that will
forever haunt you in your nightmares
now just before I announce the number
one person I thought this would be a
good time to list the honorable mentions
from a series who just failed to make
the list and recap the countdown so far
so let's start with the honorable
mentions a fro from Afro Samurai
a butt-kickin samurai voiced by samuel
l.jackson that just failed to make it
thanks to his lack of a personality
vegeta from Dragon Ball Z item a
slighter from rurouni kenshin
and he a from Hugh Hawk show all who are
badasses and kick asses in their own
respective series but unfortunately were
basically the same characters and didn't
do anything that made them stand out for
your tip was shown an antihero
Hisoka from hunter x hunter the cools
clown ever behind the Joker but
ultimately too creepy and weird to make
the list Roy Mustang from format
Alchemist because I haven't seen format
psalmist yes I know I know shut up
Kakashi from Naruto cool calm
quick-witted but Justin do enough to
break into the top 20 Lucy from elfin
leads brutal heartless and badass but
also had an annoying stupid Pokemon as a
split personality
the loose from code geass smarts
masterful but whose personality was a
bit too inconsistent while also on top
of that having a slightly weird sister
complex and now a recap of the countdown
so far number 20 Aizen so station bleach
the unshakable untouchable god that will
seize everything number 19 hey from
darken and black Chinese electric Batman
what more can I say
number 18 arson leap one third from loop
on the third though sideburns number 17
Light Yagami from Death Note everything
just goes exactly as he planned ins
number 16 motoko kusanagi from ghost in
the shell sleep strong sexy and God
badass number 15 fashion wolf would he
try gun the coolest EO in anime history
number 14 Mugen from samurai Champloo
samurais and break dancers eat your
heart out number 13 Sousa Wahiawa Jima
from dissolving anger-management the
only way he knows how
violence number 12 Kenshiro from fisted
and North Star then father putting up a
fight Spurs you are already dead number
11 dear Brando from JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure
nuff said number 10 row no zero from one
piece what happens nothing nothing at
all number 9 guts from berserk proving
how badass normal humans can be since
1990 number 8
Anika van Helsing showing Twilight fans
what real vampires should be like number
7 the counting Gong katsuo a devious
gentleman and charisma
on flight number six coming up from
growing agon just who the hell do you
think he is number five eikichi onizuka
from gto the greater teacher the world
has ever seen
kinda number four Claire Stanford in
Baccano our God in his own mind and how
he blame him
number three is balalaika from black
goon as far as females goes she is by
far the scariest number two
yo Hanley but from Monster pure evil and
the perfect monster but out of all these
characters that can only be one which
could be crowned as the king of cool
[Music]
you